well we've also just heard from the
sister of a man neil astles who died
due to a blood clot after having the
astrazeneca jab
she told sky news about the shock that
she and her family were feeling
and her belief that people should still
get their vaccine
complete complete shock really i think
and i think you start quite naturally to
feel very angry
afterwards in terms of
the whole unfairness of life
basically
there's a whole issue of why neil
which you know is a nonsensical sort of
argument really
but i think what i think the reason i'm
sat here today is because as a
pharmacist i understand
about pharmacovigilance processes
the role of the mhra the balance of
risks and meds
of risks and benefits with absolutely
every medicine that you take
and the vaccine is no different i still
strongly believe
that for the greater good of the
population and to save the maximum
number of lives that we can
with this pandemic that people should go
ahead and have their vaccine